Good morning Hank. It's Tuesday.
Vidcon is this week. In a related story haaaaaaaaaaaaaaa is the sound that my anxiety makes
So Hank I'm in a hotel in Canada at a conference about educational video featuring like CGP Grey
and VSauce and MinutePhysics and Vi Hart, tons of fascinating people
But Hank the operative word there is 'Canada'!
Because as you remember from
the last time that we went to Canada
it is not easy for me to get into Canada.
Right so this happens every time I come
to Canada, but I fly in I have my customs
forms filled out
I get in line and then I'm sent to
like the Special Immigration office for
felons and other undesirables. And then I
am asked if I've ever been denied
entrance to Canada before and I say "yes"
in 1995 I was denied entrance to your
fine country
due to insufficient funds. So Hank this was in the halcyon days before teenagers had
credit cards and when I was a freshman in
college a friend of mine and I, we drove
up to Windsor, Ontario
is it 'friend of mine and I' or 'a friend of
mine and me'?
a friend of mine and I; I was right
to begin with. I should
trust my instincts. So we drove to Windsor with a two liter bottle of Mountain Dew
a loaf of bread and some peanut butter
and fourteen dollars. I don't know by
what definition that constitutes
insufficient funds. So we try to cross
the border they search our car for
drugs then they turn us around for
insufficient funds, we go back to America
where they again search our car for
drugs, this time for three hours
even though we never got to Canada!
But it was fun we had a nice story when
we got back to college - we were too poor for Canada. And Hank I never had a problem getting into Canada
until 2001 when suddenly my name appeared on a list of undesirables.
And now every single time I go to
Canada I am forced to explain again
that in 1995 I was deemed
insufficiently wealthy to visit this
great nation! Ohhhh and then they
search my bags and let me go on my way.
So, anyway, today asked the guy is this
going to last forever? Is there any way I
can clear my name? Make a donation to
your health care system or something
that will allow me to not be on the list? And he said, and I'm quoting him directly here Hank,
"Mister Green you're gonna die on that
list". So Hank that's my story of how I became
undesirable to Canadians. Canadians,
perhaps this helps you understand why I
don't tour here more often. Also Nerdfighters if history tells us anything it's
that Hank will fail to upload his video on Friday due
to VidCon stress.
So prepare your punishment ideas and
leave them in comments.
Did I say "comments" or "comets"? I really don't
ennunciate very well for an
extensively professional video blogger.